Russia has launched a new wave of
attacks across Ukraine Defense Forces
shot down most of the estimated 100
incoming rockets and drones but some
still managed to reach their targets the
strikes left nearly half the population
of the capital Kiev without power
Trails of smoke streak across the skies
of Ukraine
as dozens of Russia missiles yet to game
better the country
key residents sheltered below the
streets in the city's Metro
in scenes reminiscent of the early days
of Russia's invasion
Samir Vitale Klitschko remains defiant
same people of Ukraine will never give
up
the Russians want to bring depression
especially right now Christmas time New
Year the the Russians want to bring us
to to Black time to without lighting to
without heating yeah they have to bring
the
depression mood to everyone instead them
Ukrainian people very angry and they
told better we stay without lipstick
without hitting but we never give up
deutschevela's Emmanuel Shays visited
one neighborhood in southern Kiev where
a missile caused extensive damage
you can see just hear the debris of that
missile that just fell earlier this
morning so the road here is completely
littered this is a neighbor completely
desolating it desolated and it's just
it's not just houses that have been
shattered it's so it's also entire lives
locals he has sifted through what little
remained of their homes
I was in the supermarket when my
granddaughter caught crying
the windows were broken and someone's
house was on fire we dropped everything
and came running and saw everything that
these animals had done they are fascists
Ukrainian military officials say dozens
of missiles were fired at Key
infrastructure targets but most were
intercepted by Ukrainian air defense
systems
Belarus has summoned the Ukrainian
Ambassador after it claimed a Ukrainian
missile entered its territory
almost a year into this war
people across Ukraine are now seeing out
2022
in the same ruinous way but it began
I'm joined Now by Thomas vigold a
military and defense journalist based
here in Berlin I'd like to start by
taking a look at the bigger picture here
we know Russia has been intensively
targeting Power and Water Supplies in
Ukraine since October but what effect is
this having in the war
well actually we are seeing two Wars we
see in a ground war in Ukraine in the
East and the South and we are seeing
this war against civilian infrastructure
which is mostly the energy grid uh
transformation stations water equipment
all this stuff so this is what happened
today again a massive wave against the
civilian infrastructure let's talk about
that other War then in the East and the
South we know Russian missile attacks
have been coming quite far from the
front lines do you expect that Russia is
going to step up its ground offensive as
well
no I don't think so um the point is it
seems not really synchronized we've seen
these air attacks with cruise missiles
with ballistic missiles was drawn since
October and this is completely out of
sync with what is going on on the ground
the offensive there counter-offensives
are following a completely different
schedule
so what should we be watching there
specifically
we should watch out I don't think for
much happening on the ground in the next
weeks but we should keep an eye on these
civilian infrastructure on the energy
grid which is getting really really a
problem for key of authorities for the
government of Ukraine because when you
look at Ukraine today Ukraine claimed of
16 missiles which attacked 16 were shot
down which is a pretty good tally but if
you look at other areas other regions
it's not quite as good and every missile
would get through means new damage to
the grid indeed and looking ahead what
do you think the prospects are for
negotiations the Kremlin has rejected a
plan from president zielinski this week
instead demanding the key of accept
Russian annexation of four regions
well the problem is if you look at what
Russia calls negotiation for offer for
negotiation it's actually not
negotiation it's a call for surrender
and I think as long as this call of
surrender persists Ukraine is not in a
position to agree on anything
all right thank you so much for taking
the time to speak with us on DW news
that's Thomas vigold a freelance
military and defense journalist